a party at the house of a friend 11
o'clock on a still warm evening a meter
away from you a group of people are
chatting animatedly someone is telling
an anecdote it might be something about
a train ride they took or the mishaps on
someone's bicycle and their companions
break in occasionally with rich laughter
and stories of their own the group as a
whole
seemed confident and attractive and the
main narrator especially so but there
may as well be a high solid brick wall
or a lamprey filled moat between you and
they there is resolutely no way you
could ever move in to say hello you
smile your characteristic weak losers
smile pretend to study the bookshelf and
leave the gathering
ten minutes later much of the advice is
about what one might say in the
circumstances it could be better to
start somewhere else with what one
should think chronic shyness is a guess
about what other people are like though
it doesn't feel like it when it's
flooded us shyness reflects a rationally
founded assessment as to the nature and
intentions of other members of our
species it's not a chemical imbalance or
an impulse it's a philosophy albeit a
deeply unhelpful one the essential
assumption in shyness is that other
people are self-sufficient that they
don't lack for company that they're not
alone with anything that they understand
all they need to know and that they
don't share in any of our frailties
hesitation secret longings or confusions
this occurs in an adult form the
assumptions a child might make of their
teacher a competent Stern grown-up who
appears never to have been young silly
tender or interested in a pillow fight
this lack of faith in the humanity of
others is a natural tendency of our
minds we go by the external cues and few
people feel safe enough to display their
vulnerabilities we therefore come to
assume that we are living among superior
metal-plated cyborgs rather than fragile
water-filled uncertain entities
we can't believe that most of what we
know of our own minds especially the
self-doubt the anxiety and the sadness
must exist in the minds of strangers as
well we forget that we also give off few
signals as to what we're really like we
too are filled with emotions and
interests that we inadvertently end up
hiding that others might not normally
expect of us and that could easily lead
a stranger to misjudge us and feel
intimidated but we're slow to convert
this crucial insight into a social
strategy into a confidence inducing
knowledge that others must also as we do
harbour requisite doses of warmth
longing curiosity and sorrow the
ingredients from which new friendships
can be built a seemingly happily married
person might have a lot of agony around
the course of their relationship a
pugnacious sportsman might suffer from
chronic anxiety and shame a CEO might
have vivid memories of their struggles
in a lot of space in their imagination
for people whose careers have yet to
take off a very intellectual person
might internally be longing for a new
friend who could patiently encourage
them to dance or forgive their inept
gyrations our error is to suppose that
the way a person seems is the whole of
who they are our anxiety closes off the
core fact that we are all much more
approachable than we seem the key to
self belief and to the mindset to talk
to strangers successfully doesn't lie in
strenuously insisting on our own merits
its source is a more accurate and less
forbidding mode of imagining the inner
lives and especially the inner troubles
of strangers please comment like and
subscribe and take a look at our shop
for more from the school of life
you